news daily from science mission
individuals exposed to repeated stress a
major trigger of depression increase
their caffeine intake but the mechanism
underlying this protective effect is
unknown in an animal model of chronic
unpredictable stress researchers saw
enhanced adenosine receptors in synapses
and the Selective elimination of these
receptors in neurons abrogated stress
induced changes caffeine blocked
adenosine receptors and hence could be
tried as a possible target in humans
next moonlighting proteins are recept
class of multifunctional proteins whose
functions are unrelated by combining
network topological information with
protein annotations researchers identify
for the first time 430 extreme
multifunctional proteins they form a
distinct subgroup of proteins
characterized by specific features which
form a signature of extreme
multi-functionality they are enriched in
linear motifs and less intrinsically
disordered than network hubs for more
details visitors at
www.sentinelsource.com/site/forms/subscription